nowadays you see a lot more mexican
rappers waving the flag and [ __ ] but
back then there was none trust me like i
always tell everybody like i think you
kind of broke the
mold of where like how we look at
mexican embassies because back then
it was we just automatically went to
like thinking of like little rob
and and those guys and and um there was
some guys that were like obviously you
know
super dope like psycho realm like cyber
sales [ __ ] like that but like
i feel like in your era like you were
the first person to come along
even the record you do to mc magic and
twista you were like snapping
yeah i remember because that's the first
time i ever heard you and i remember
hitting magic
like who's this girl in this song who
could really rap yeah and we had done
that track
like a year or two before but it didn't
drop till i started kind of picking
myself up you know what i mean so i
think
because i've seen somebody recently be
like you know that chicano rap you know
gay open the door for me or whatever and
i'm like look
all respected chicano rap and i and i
feel that but at the same time we're
talking about hip-hop and being mexican
and and it's like there is sonically
musically a difference you know what i
mean and it's like
it's not because i think any less of it
because it's dope like i'll get on a
feature or something but
i just come from hip-hop you know what i
mean like it's it's kind of like if
there's like soundcloud rap right now or
some some sort of like type of music and
i'm like yo
like you know i did like nah like we got
to know the difference between sonically
like or genres or whatever the [ __ ] you
know
but um with me with that that whole
waving the flag [ __ ] i feel like i was
doing it out of the need because i
didn't see it it wasn't because i was
like i'm gonna be the one it was just
kind of like yo i don't see
it being done so let me you know i think
you were the first like you're the first
artist in a long time that
was dope that happened to be mexican as
opposed to seeing a mexican artist as a
like
yo like like like when you think of
little rob
and i [ __ ] with rob that's you know what
i'm saying and he's got some [ __ ]
classics you know what i'm saying but
when i think a little rob i think of
like
yeah he's mexican and oh and you think
of him like you're like a dope rapper
first
and then it's like oh [ __ ] she's mexican
i didn't i wouldn't even have known you
know what i'm saying
i i think i think it's just like i said
sonically and the the
the [ __ ] how you grew up you know i i
grew up listening to
like e40 and mac dre and too short and
big
and pun and like you know lauren hill
and and the outcast and it's like
that's it's just a different and it's
like no offense you know what i mean
like i i don't
it's just different it's not the same
you feel me yeah and for example and i
had to take the hits for that because
at the same time i would go to a a car
show
and perform and the [ __ ] all the
trolls in the crowd would look at me
like what the [ __ ] is this [ __ ] doing
this girl yeah straight up you know or
like you know i've i've had to be in
those rooms
where you know there's somebody checking
me and being like oh you're you know
what i mean like you
would you chase another at races for
like we have to deal with our
colorism and our issues and our [ __ ]
culture
you know with with um with crossing
those
those lines and [ __ ] and i've had to
teach my family my friends like yo
this is how you talk this is why that's
wrong you need to i've stopped talking
to most of my [ __ ] family for the
same reason for being
homophobic for being halfway racist for
being colorist like
when you go through all those things and
you've took in the hits for all those
things when i speak
about the experience that i've had i
also hope that people
respect where i'm coming from when i'm
like chicano rap didn't necessarily open
the door for me
um because i had to kind of open another
door for myself